- Okay, here we go.
Going in now to see the Vision Pro.
No photos, no video?
- [Man] No.
- So I have good news and bad news.
The good news,
I did get to try out Apple's
new Mixed Reality Headset.
Bad news, Apple wouldn't
let us film me wearing it.
Thus, we're here.
They did let us film
the headset on a table.
Roll that footage.
(upbeat music)
But yes, I did get to spend 30
minutes wearing the headset,
which is really focused on
bringing digital objects
into your real world.
Roll footage from the keynote.
- [Presenter] Games on a
giant screen surrounded
by spatial audio,
and connect with people as if
you're sharing the same space.
- I got to see a few of
those demos in the headset,
which is by far the best
AR/VR headset I've ever used,
but it's still a headset.
Let me take you through it from here.
Let's start with what it's
like to wear this thing.
Honestly, it felt like Apple
stuck a giant Apple Watch
to my head, in a good way.
The sock-like headband was easy to put on
and adjust the size with the knob.
Oh, look, Tim Cook showed
up, not wearing the headset.
For the first 15 minutes of the demo,
I couldn't believe how comfortable it was,
far cozier than the Meta
Quests Pro or the Quest 2.
A lot of that is because
the battery lives in a pack
that's attached to the headset.
Behold, battery pack footage.
(upbeat music)
Honestly, the battery, which
is said to last only two hours,
was pretty light and easy
to fit in my back pocket,
but it's still a lot of tech on your face.
By the end of the demo,
the top of my nose and forehead
started to feel the weight.
Here's a photo of me when I took it off.
I guess this is why so much
of the footage from Apple
is of people alone in their homes.
- [Presenter] With a spatial cinema
that transforms any space,
like this apartment,
you have a gorgeous screen you can adjust
to the perfect size.
- Apple says that discomfort
was because it only had
limited sized light seals,
which fit the headset to your face.
There will be more options
when the device is
available early next year.
Okay, so what's it like to
look through this thing?
Pretty insane,
especially compared to
other headsets out there.
Apple is really focusing on
blending the digital world
with your real world,
and you can really toggle
between a VR-like experience
where you're in a virtual world,
and an AR-like experience
where digital objects show up
in your real world.
Spin the digital crown one way
and you'll see more of the real world,
spin it the other and you see less.
Press on the button and you
get taken to the home screen,
and it, again, really worked like that.
Even better,
looking at the real world
looks crisp and clear,
unlike the Meta Quests Pro
where things can look grainy.
But going back and forth between AR and VR
did make me feel a little bit queasy
by the end of the demo.
It wasn't like a puke situation,
but you know, just, nah.
Unlike other VR headsets,
there are no controllers,
so your eyes are your cursor
and your fingers are
like the mouse buttons.
To select things, you
just pinch like this.
And then to scroll,
you move it in different directions.
And yes, one of the craziest
things is the front screen,
where people who look at
you can see your eyes.
No, I didn't test this,
but look at what we made in Photoshop.
Okay, so what do you do with it?
During the demo, I was able to
scatter a few apps in space,
so instead of having multiple monitors,
you could just look at
these virtual screens
around your room.
I was also able to have a FaceTime chat
with an Apple employee, except
it wasn't a video of her,
it was a 3D hologram of her.
During the call, she was
able to launch a presentation
for us to work together on.
And the coolest thing was probably
the 3D spatial photos and videos.
A dedicated button on the
top left of the headset
will allow wearers to snap these photos,
though I couldn't try it myself.
And I watched a 3D movie
clip and was very into it.
Do we need more things to
do with the Vision Pro,
especially to justify
its $3,500 price tag?
Absolutely,
but that's why Apple's getting
it out now to developers
so they can dream up new experiences.
Are we all gonna buy this
when it comes out next year?
Nope.
But this vision of spatial
computing, as Apple calls it,
and seeing the digital in our real world
really does feel like the next big thing,
even if it does seem,
at its present moment,
a bit dystopian and isolating.
And I do look forward to
trying the Vision Pro again
and filming what's actually happening,
instead of more of this.
(upbeat music)